escuelas transporte público suministro
de combustibles se pueden garantizar
estos servicios durante una huelga en
Francia algunos trabajadores como los
militares los policías y los
funcionarios de prisiones no pueden
declararse en huelga otros como los
empleados de hospitales controladores
aéreos y locutores públicos pueden ser
obligados a ir a trabajar en
determinadas condiciones el pasado
octubre el gobierno obligó a los
huelguistas de cinco refinerías de
combustibles a volver al trabajo para
evitar la escasez de gasolina en 2007 el
entonces presidente Nicolás intentó
ampliar la ley de servicios mínimos al
transporte público y el proyecto fue
aprobado a partir de ahora cuando los
franceses hagan huelga nadie se dará
cuenta de hecho la ley sólo obliga a los
trabajadores a anunciar su intención de
huelga con 48 horas de antelación
exige el preaviso para que las empresas
de transporte puedan intentar organizar
un servicio mínimo
no exige un servicio mínimo
el transporte público es el sector en el
que la acción laboral tiende a imponer
las máximas molestias a los ciudadanos
franceses no obstante los requisitos de
servicios mínimos se van atenuados por
el derecho constitucional francés a la
huelga